Witcher 3 developer CD Projekt RED has
said that developing for the PlayStation
4 and Xbox one has allowed it to go nuts
in terms of visuals I'm mark Walton and
this is a game spot news update The
Witcher 3 might have abandoned its
planned for launch in favor of a 2015
date for that extra development time
isn't going to waste speaking to The
Sydney Morning Herald Witcher threes
global head of marketing said I think
we're in a good moment we don't have to
choose between better graphics or
performance on either pc or consoles now
we can just create the best looking game
possible he also said that only the
future will tell if the witcher 3 is
maxing out the consoles technical
capabilities noting that game's release
on xbox 360 and playstation 3 continue
to look better even after all these
years we are always getting wiser and
wiser so I expect our next game will
look even better CD Projekt RED CEO
previously said that the witcher 3 is
fairly close to maxing out the power of
the xbox one and ps4 so what do you guys
think is the prospect of a maxout xbox
one or Playstation 4 enough to soften
the blow of Adelaide which 3 let us know
in the comments below and keep it here
for more gamespot news